[Music]  Channing Tatum and Jenna Dewan have  split the couple is calling it quits  after eight years of marriage Channing  and Jenna met in 2006 while filming step  up their on-screen romance was so  electric it heated up off-screen as well  they tied the knot in 2009 and welcomed  their daughter Everly in 2013 et has  been with the pair throughout the years  they were never shy about professing  their love for one another I think he'll  be the most my birthday it was a nice  surprise  always really good surprise sweatpants  in the t-shirt I mean okay well Jenna  gush about him when you find it last  month  Jenna admitted in Health magazine that  their marriage wasn't always perfect she  said quote we fight like other couples  we disagree about things we have days  where we don't really like each other  [Music]  [Applause]